this is a production of Cornell
University all right so I'm gonna talk
about my research today focused on
understanding resistance to Phytophthora
root and Crown rot in squash and pumpkin
mm-hmm so I'm gonna start by talking a
little bit about pathogen that causes
this disease it's a soil borne Oh my
seed pathogen called quite a threat at
caps BC and it causes root stem and
fruit rots on a variety of different
plant species so just a couple things I
want to mention about the biology of
this pathogen that have big implications
in terms of disease management the first
of those is that when you have sexual
reproduction happen with two different
main types this pathogen you get really
Hardy thick-walled spores that can
overwinter and survive dormant in the
soil for many years meaning that when
this pathogen was introduced to a new
field it's almost impossible for a
farmer to eradicate and he or she needs
to at that point on the other hand
asexual reproduction produces much more
short-lived spores but they actually
have flagella and can swim through the
water so when soil is saturated these
zou spores are released swim through
soil finding plants to infect and
disease can escalate very rapidly given
the right environmental conditions so
there are many plants that are
susceptible to disease caused by fight a
three captaincy the most economically
important of those are some nation
species especially peppers cubits and
some leggings as well so I'm gonna talk
specifically about one of the host
species of this pathogen and that is
carbonate pipo which is one of the three
species of squash pumpkin that we grow
in the United States and this is
actually the most economically valuable
of those squash species it includes
modern classes like zucchini other types
of summer squash acorn squash and
pumpkins so Kakeru to pipo compared to
some other cucurbits is particularly
susceptible to a root and Crown rot
caused by Phytophthora caps you see in
other key Kermit's like cucumbers
fruit rot is a bigger concern
currently people is very sensitive in
roots and stems so these are this is my
typical crown rot symptoms look like
disease is first observed as a
water-soaked lesion at the base of the
stem that will then constrict the stem
the plant will die and often you'll see
sporulation on that dead tissue so
breeding for resistance to Phytophthora
root and Crown rot in squash has been
very challenging and there are no
cultivars that are marketed as
resistance as resistant so if I talk
through crown wrap and the biggest
obstacle that we have is that we have
yet to identify any sources of complete
resistance in concurrent people however
we do observe differences between
different gene types in terms of how
long it takes plants of those genotypes
to die and that's what we're trying to
take advantage of in our breeding
program so we've done a little bit of
work trying to understand whether this
can be characterized as resistance or
tolerance
we've done some confocal microscopy
using a gfp-tagged pathogen isolate and
we found that plants from genotypes that
tend to survive longer also tend to have
a less degree of pathogen colonization
in their root tissue three days after
inoculation
similarly we used quantitative PCR to
estimate pathogen biomass in stem tissue
three days after inoculation here I'm
showing on the x-axis a visual rating of
disease severity for 11 different
genotypes on the y-axis is the content
of PCR based measurement of tangent
biomass and again the genotypes that
tend to have more severe disease
symptoms meaning that the plants die
more quickly also tend to have a greater
degree of pathogen biomass in their
tissue so I think it's fair to describe
this as resistance where the plant is
actually able to impede the growth of
pathogens tissue rather than tolerance
where the pathogens
survives infects equally well but the
plants able to deal with it somehow
I also want to mention quickly that
you'll see really large standard
deviation bars whether you're looking at
visual ratings in term for disease
severity or actually measuring the
amount of patandjill in tissue and
that's an obstacle that we encounter
with its padlet system where there's a
great degree of plant to plant variation
in terms of how it responds to
inoculation to plants of the same gene
type one might have ten thousand times
more pathogen biomass in that plant at
the same time point after inoculation so
it makes it very challenging to breed
and particularly to select based on
single plant size regardless we've been
making progress at Cornell breeding for
increased resistance so if it's a fruit
rot we've used an accession called
Austrian Bush as a source of antenna
resistance this is what's called a
vegetable marrow type squash selection
has been performed at the ceiling stage
in the greenhouse and here at the on the
right side of the slide I'm showing some
results from the two years of field
trials we've done the past two years
these are very condensed results and in
particular I'm just showing two entries
in these field trials the reason for
that if these two gene types are the
appearance of the metric population that
I'll be talking about later so this one
entry is a susceptible zucchini cultivar
called Dungey we also have a Cornell
breeding line and you can see it 17 days
after inoculation some qualitative
differences in terms of the response
inoculation however if you continue to
observe those plants you'll see I have
that it takes on average about a week
and a half to kill 50 percent of the
dungeon plants in the field whereas it
takes a month to kill 50 percent of the
plants of this particular breeding line
so we've made progress in selecting for
increased resistance compared to
acceptable commercial cultivars
we still have a little bit of work to do
in terms of getting a level of
resistance that's economically relevant
or acceptable for growers in order to
understand a little bit about the
genetic architecture of this trait and
develop markers that can be used in
breeding we performed QTL mapping like I
said the susceptible parent was that
Dungey zucchini and the resistant parent
was actually an F for selection that was
the progenitor of that breeding line in
the previous slide so we elected to use
a next-generation sequencing Volks
arrogant analysis approach I'll talk a
little bit about why we decided to do
that but first I'll just walk through
the experimental design a little bit
so we evaluated 7,000 seedlings in the
greenhouse inoculated them with the
pathogen and selected the 15% of the
population that were the most resistant
individuals and the 15% most susceptible
individuals we also chose 15% random
plants to serve as the control bulk and
we did this twice so almost 14,000
plants but we had two independent we
selected resistant and susceptible
plants so we took leaf punches from
those plants isolated and pooled their
DNA gave those DNA pools our codes and
holding them resequenced them on two
lanes of the next week 500 with Heron
and 150 base pair reads so there are
advantages and disadvantages to this
type of QTL mapping approach compared to
conventional QTL mapping for our
purposes the main advantage is the
phenotyping is relatively easy instead
of assigning the epic scores to every
individual in this population we just
had to identify the phenotypic extremes
so this enabled us to evaluate a larger
population which is important for this
trait where we observe such low single
tiered abilities
so we use standard bioinformatics lines
to trim the reads align them to the
reference genome and call variants we
then filtered these snips to just
include those that were fixed for
opposite alleles and the parents which
we also sequenced and we got rid of
snips with extreme allele frequencies or
extreme read dips and I just want to
mention that what we take from the
sequence data from these pools is not a
measure of a genotype on an individual
but the counts of the alleles that are
sequenced so if you're familiar with the
VCF file this is the part that we're
interested in the number of counts of
the reference allele and the number of
counts of the alternate allele for each
pool and at each marker so we achieved
fairly high read oops which we were
pleased with because with this type of
experimental approach the pools are
composed of many individuals and there's
lots of error from sampling of raids
during sequence II so you need to have a
high read depth murder accurately
estimate the allele frequencies at these
markers snips covered the whole genome
fairly evenly although there are some
regions better represented than others
so this this is kind of busy but I'll
try to focus on some of the regions in a
little bit I'm just going to introduce
what I'm showing here and this is the
frequency of the allele derived from the
resistant parent in each of the five DNA
pools two pools too susceptible pools
too resistant pools and one random pool
in any region that's not in LD with
polymorphism that affects the trait we
expect the low frequencies in these five
rules to being the same taking an
account some noise from sampling
individuals and from sequencing error so
that's what we see for example on
chromosome three the frequencies in
these five pools all they fluctuate
across the chromosome but they don't
deviate from one another
but chromosome 4 however if you look at
the end of the chromosome you'll see
that the two resistant pools in green
are enriched for the allele that's
inherited from the resistant period and
the two susceptible pools are depleted
for that allele and the random pool has
intermediate allele frequencies which is
a pretty convincing signature of some
polymorphism in that region affecting
the trait that we selected upon we see
something similar at the beginning of
chromosome five on chromosome eight we
see a similar pattern in that the
resistant and susceptible pools have
different allele frequencies but we
observe all the pools to deviate in the
same direction from 0.5 and this could
be because of segregation distortion or
some artifact from mapping combined with
a polymorphism that affects differences
the frequency in each pool so chromosome
16 at the end of chromosome 16 we
observe similar signature however here
you'll notice that the resistant parent
the resistant pools I should say are
actually enriched for the allele that's
derived from the susceptible suggesting
that there are good alleles from both
parents of the mutant population so many
ways have been published to perform a
positive testing with this type of
experimental design and data set this is
one method which I'm showing here called
multi pool which takes into account
recombination rates and all the markers
simultaneously on a chromosome to
estimate LOD scores in 100 base pair
intervals and as you'll see whether you
use the data just from RIP one or rep
two we have large peaks in those regions
I just mentioned chromosomes 4 5 8 and
16 you get higher Peaks when you combine
data from both of the ribs because you
have a larger sample size and greater
raid depth there are also other regions
where we observe minor Peaks
consistently between both of the rips
suggesting that there probably other
minor QTL involved
but we don't have the statistical power
to confidently declare Qt owners so what
do we learn from this experiment well we
learned that resistance appears
polygenic there are desirable alleles
from both periods and with this type of
experiment design we we're not able to
actually estimate QTL effect sizes but
we do observe that even in the regions
with the strongest signal the absolute
magnitude in terms of the allele
frequency differences between the pools
was fairly small around 10 to 15 percent
so this could be because of poor
accuracy in visual selection again
because of all the plant variation or
because the actual effect sizes of these
QTL are fairly small so in order to
evaluate how effective marker-assisted
selection can be for i Tophet root and
Crown rot resistance in squash we're
currently developing an F to three
population will be able to use the gene
types of the F to parents and the
phenotypes of three progeny to compare
the predictive performance of markers in
QTL regions to whole genome markers
using whole genome prediction models so
with that I'd like to thank all the
members of the smart and wor labs my
committee members Mike Gore Chris smart
Michael moobs Eric and Philip Messer
Kyle LaPlante from the Missouri lab
who's worked on a lot of breeding for
resistance and squash summer scholars
Ella Reeves and Jessica halvah could did
the lot of the qPCR and microscopy
experiments and funding from New York
State Department of Agriculture markets
and the USDA thank you
[Applause]
yes each of the books with a different
tag no there are only two DNA samples so
each sample represented DNA pulled from
all those individuals within that
breadth system did you did you simple
your acceptable lines on the way out or
did you did she sample everything and
that we just sampled those individuals
that were selected so we waited a couple
days after inoculation found those
plants that first started to wilt first
and took tissue punches from those
samples and then we waited another five
to seven days for the plants that held
out the longest and selected those as
the resistive almost like sexual
reproduction could you you know flood a
field with like sterilized to like just
[Music]
that's that's an interesting idea I
haven't really thought about it might be
hard to convince a farmer to flood their
field with right yeah that's an
interesting idea it might be hard to
maybe in like a newly infected field but
the OHS force the sexual spores they
vary in how long they take to germinate
we have evidence to those borders
germinating seven years later and
starting infecting plants so if you
already have that bank of spores in the
soil might be kind of hard to overpower
that but maybe with a newly infected
field
all right thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu